bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e dolci andiamo
avanti con il braga scusatemi tantissimo
se dagli ultimi episodi possano più di
una settimana avevo promesso che l'avrei
fatto presto invece passata più di una
settimana raga scusate mi ero finito in
una situazione di merda dato io sto
gioco ragazzi e fantastico io il digiuno
che è fantastico
l'uscita è bloccata si vabè eravamo
rimasti qui mi stava mi stava stuprando
sto manichino allora e non mi ricordo
che tasto da premere mi pare questo di
mezzo non vorrei fare cazzate ad altre
un attimo tagli dire [ __ ]
ok ok ok il dribbling bustone blue bland
fra i premi ok ok aperto lo vedi lo vedi
questo amica mia lo vedi se non lo vedi
perché non c'è la testa ma guardano lo
stesso o che va dai ragazzi ci siamo in
uno capitol anche che cazzo ci sono
passato a fare li dentro un giorno lei è
un bell'uomo che quadro scoraggiante è
bestie che mi scoraggio di più la testa
del manichino cosa le luci
ok se vendo tutto rega appena riaccende
lo fanno la terza sorpresa è troppo buio
non vedo niente ibc 6
sì sì sono stai tranquillo meno male
resta qui ok si lo so che ti sta cagando
addossa che non fai la femminuccia nei
momenti sbagliati sono qui accanto a te
non ti preoccupare ma questo è un
problema a giusto ho dimenticato di
avere un accendino
non lo zio fermo lo sapevo perché cazzo
successo che cazzo è passato un bambino
col pennarello
vento ragazzi alla radio non so chi
cazzo ha scritto con la cosa sul muro né
tantomeno so perché ci sono dei passi e
perché è spuntata una stanza segreta di
qua non lo capisco chi cazzo sei tu
regalo chi è ma perché gli ha tirato un
calcio ai marchi madonna e manesca sta
ragazza stai bene prima di chili un
calciopolì chiedi se stai bene dopo
andando in giro per vedere se c'era
qualcun altro deve uscire quindi sì lo
sapevo vorresti venire con noi ma per me
sì berrò perfetto ragazzi ci siamo in
tre
adesso ce ne manca due facciamo gli one
direction adesso è deciso come ti chiami
mary ok siamo i big harry e mary
fantastico e piacere va bene ora che
abbiamo più compagnia possiamo procedere
a testa alta perfetto
ok ragazzi e adesso siamo in tre c'è
mica va cosa da fare questo quadro a
fiori di gelosia
no evidentemente perfetto ciao cioè
cos'è è un pokémon robot cos'è sta roba
sottoscritto soffre
[Musica]
io non ho fatto un cazzo è tornavento da
coniglio si è rotto qualcosa tre
frammenti ottenuto chiave viola ok si è
suicidato da solo al coniglio perfetto
un sonno viene dal quadro ok questo no
si stava avvicinando
ok ragazzi che cazzo succede
cos'è che cosa ci trova pavimento questo
non va bene allontanatevi dal quadro
attenta
ok mi ha quasi stuprato il quadro
perfetto dove stai garry state tutte e
due bene possiamo trovare qualcosa per
sbarazzarci di queste cose in un'altra
stanza
andiamo a cercare spero che starete bene
faremo bene giusto i ball credo di sì
vai così andiamo mai perfetto ragazzi
possiamo andarcene qui
mi spiace la sua di terni ma abbiate
pazienza se no non si va avanti qui non
vedo niente di utile perfetto clinici di
tornare da garry per ora torniamo la
carrie che cosa che è successo senti
allora sei nuova del posto tu non sai
che si sono dei cali di corretta uscita
che c'è si fa quella di mezzo togliti
quella quella quando si è mossa non era
contro il muro sposta live
spingi non si muove niente soltanto
garry c'è la forza di braccio di ferro
amica mia mi dispiace cosa facciamo ibra
non possiamo fare aiutato a portare di
qua imperfetto la mangiamo di qua
che ci devo fare una previa chi cazzo è
quel tizio una finestra chissà cosa sta
facendo garry l'abbiamo lasciato
indietro e non è colpa mia se non
troviamo roba che fa ci mettono tempo
chissà se è successo qualcosa e mary mi
sentite sapevo che non avrei dovuto
lasciarla andare da sole che fare è che
fai ospiti fuoco che cazzo ne so credo
che investigano ancora in quella stanza
nonostante o divida ritorna lì dentro
sono io che harry bastardo che ci ha 10
lode non me lo dice ma sto stronzo
ok dove sta dei bei coniglietti di prima
comunque è una bambola disturbante sono
tutti i bambini disturbanti che cazzo ci
stiamo a fare qui dentro
niente di interessante prima ok
sei un [ __ ] genio ti chiamerò
sherlock da adesso in avanti è spostato
perché non ho votato prima posso uscire
di qui o che usciamo che cazzo siamo
regata l'altro certo cosa rosso che non
ho capito che cazzo è serve poi fossero
è ok ho capito siamo praticamente posso
passare dai a gerry non c'è movimento
che perfetto da posso passare dagli
bagheri come cazzo voglio perfetto sa
cosa mi piace un casino un accordo
allora credo che io debba tirare la
corda giusta vado completamente abuso
perché non so quali sono ok è servito a
qualcosa
completamente a caso raga non ci posso
ma veramente io ultimamente ciò più culo
che altro è bloccato st porta si è
bloccato la credo che debba collaborare
con i b per poterci passare perché è
incredibile che ci sia gli uffici passa
vero riguarda possiamo attraversare nei
sei sicura
credo di sì ma io non mi fiderei tanto
di sta tizia
ok ok perfetto non si è cagato addosso
qualcosa si muove al suo interno non
aprire quella scatola io la pro non me
ne frega un cazzo
non posso aprire perché si porta
perfetto allora andiamo avanti così che
cazzo è successo ho buone gare di
qualche cosa c'è di preciso allora non
ho capito che cazzo mi servono sostanze
assurdo che cazzo mi è così che cos'è
sto corridoio enorme
cos'è cos'è sta roba ragazze c'è ci sono
quadri che pescatore non c'è nessuno
comunque raga non si sa dove cazzo sto
andando cos'è sta roba
mio dio sono spariti colori e ti rosa mi
ha messo le rosa anche se non avevo
perse saranno che cazzo è ok perfetto
come non detto che non aveva perso rose
e adesso non posso curarmi nei grandi
cose devo passare a casa ecco cosa
serviva sto coso che ha detto che l'ho
preso dovrei riuscirci a mostrare nero
ok ragazzi su ciò che cos'è sta roba
un'altra bambola una bambola disturbante
ciao gerry non mi piace essere sola
portami con te ma a sorrento che ti
porto con me ma sei brutta come non so
cosa va a fan culo
ok forse mi sembra che dovrei rivalutare
la situazione
perché non mi stai portando perché sei
grotta battere quel che mi sta ignorando
mio di siti odio se brutta sempre
altissima ragazzini sta facendo paura è
il gioca con me conosco un sacco di cose
divertenti da fare via da qui
ragazzi vi sta facendo cagare addosso
abbastanza secondo me e mi stupra il
prima possibile proprio sono convinto
stai qui per sempre
togliti dai [ __ ] per questo che
ancora mi seguì rai
adesso basta sono occupate non diventerò
il tuo amichetto calcio la nel muro
esposta la via calcio la nel muro queste
stupide bambole battere via
ok perfetto sono stato violento ma non
me ne frega un cazzo
fa male fa male non me ne frega niente
ok sono stato violentissimo e sta cosa
qua sarà cos'è la maniglia e stranamente
fredda il cazzo me ne frega a me che la
maniglia fred amico mio
perché c'è un fiore che spunta la sua
porta io veramente non ci sto capendo
più un cazzo cosa dovrei fare qui va
dunque la tavolata ok
devo colorare la stanza di prima una
specie di piedistallo raccogliere 7
palle di bernie anno pensavo alle sette
sfere del drago la stanza sarà colorata
e il tuo ponte sarà creato palle di
vernice è che cosa sono ok perfetto
ragazzi dovrà raccogliere le palle di
vernice per far passare le due tizi e
sotto e una cielo già allora prendi da
un attimo che perfetto ne mancano sei
ragazzi con il credo che sono
esattamente al piano di sotto cosa è
questa una testa di manichino chissà se
ha un corpo toni va dal tavolo togli la
togli la perché io sono sono sprezzante
leggeri con il pezzo della testa di
manichino ti ha fatto male o che
perfetto pensavo peggio
qualcosa sul tavolo la chiave ad albero
ok che cazzo ne faccio credo ce vole j
[Musica]
buongiorno deve entrare qui dentro sono
ti dispiace che devo mettere la chiave
ad albero qua dentro questa la chiave io
direi di suonare la chiama davvero
perché il dito che cazzo ci faccio
funzionato ok non ho capito bene che
cazzo ho fatto ma qualcosa ho fatto di
sicuro non ho capito bene a questa
perfetto
chi cazzo sei tu ragazzi e allora brutta
gioco ma ve li forti cazzi tuoi oli
essenziali del colore descrivergli utile
ai colori ok che culo o c'è qualcosa per
te hanno tenuto a parlare a vernice
verde perfetto
ne abbiamo quattro l'importante è che ce
l'abbiamo 4 che è già qualcosa che cazzo
è successo ha messo ha messo i pallini
landoni ok ok si è tolto qualcosa
batterà tenuta pare non me ne frega
niente ragazzi c'era una pizza qui c'era
una [ __ ] tizia ma dopo una volta
caccia ma c'è l'uomo appreso 6219 come
faccio da una pagina m mary l'ultima
opera in assoluta russia è perfetto
allora che cazzo c'è un ritratto
familiare dall'altra parte della pagina
perché non può essere quella e mary
ok non esiste che cosa significa ed ecco
niba adesso o no ragazzi è quella non è
una tizia della galleria e una tizia dai
quadri la dedizione 292 di dati
ok ragazzi sta succedendo il caso allora
tu la devi finire di farsi i cazzi tuoi
ho preso qualcosa di bello e non te la
do ne faccio il mio tesoro sai dove te
lo infilo marakah devo tornare la juve è
certo secondo l'inps e nella merda ok
per te come non detto l'ha già lasciata
in disparte mary c'è qualcosa che non va
mai stai bene
sì sto bene sto bene bene bene bene bene
bene ok un po di citrosodina e passa
tutto
i ragazzi perfetto questo è più pazza
del solito i big ben e mary sto bene
mary io questo si fa di eroina ragazzo
va a bella di zio dove cazzo mai
d'andata era da che cosa stai facendo il
make up sentite yo yo la lascerei
volentieri a farsi i cazzi sua quale
ragazzino vi lascio rilascio così perché
dalla prossima diventerà assurdo io lo
so perché l'ho già registrata mentre vi
giuro che mi sto amando da morire questo
gioco perché epico fantastico cazzo
cherin e che per questo episodio
possiamo concludere qui come al solito
se vi dove è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come nido tratta nella
descrizione essere tali siti scrivete
noi ci divertiamo il prossimo video beh
ragazzi